How would you use planning to develop an agent that can
answer Raven's progressive matrices? So, the first question you want to ask here
is what are our states? What's our initial state? And what's our final state?
Given that, what are the operators that allow the transition between them.
How would we select those operators?
We are talking about partial ordering planning in this lesson,
what conflicts are possible when we are trying to solve Raven's problems?
How would we detect those conflicts beforehand and avoid them? Note that again
we can consider this at two different levels. First, we can think of the agent
as having a plan for how to address any new problem that comes in. Or second, we
can consider the agent as discerning the underlying plan behind a new problem.